so I'm changing the words to
Adrenaline so if you do this you get
what I call an adrenaline pump of Co
that feels oh I feel I'm getting bigger
I feel more like a monster you know so
you so to me it's Coke you but if you're
going to just go
halfheartedly you're not going to about
to stimulate
your your adrenaline
so I'm seeing lots of different things
please I me
so she and Aggie was the hand thumb up
the wrist must be
flat don't a lot of you are bringing
this arm up to about here and they
you're finding it difficult to get under
them
wherever like with the John's Point
wherever this is that's the level that
you go at you don't want to disturb that
so you you some of you are understanding
this this wants to be as upright as
possible and again someone said to me go
that's quite powerful on your own wrist
isn't it doing that and it is yes you
know some people do press UPS like
that so you do have to really work at
that so this one was shaggi
and you're going to be
really so simplified what is if the
thumb goes
down C the go so now we've got two
techniques just by
one
feeling all right so we got two Tech so
like I said today is all about
hands sheer Naggy
gosh it doesn't matter to me
um but you need to pump up your
adrenaline so I'm trying to get you all
to actually feel bigger than you
are you go through stages some of you go
through what I call an ego stage when
you pump up your
adrenaline yeah I'm start I can throw
them now so but that's right sense us to
say if all you have is strength use it
it turns to Coke you your partner might
not like that attitude
but she
nagging
K all right so we're making now
simplified iido aren't we simplified sh
naggi
kod the only difference between the she
footwork one and the K footwork is too
it's really quite simple isn't
it
shagi K what's Halfway shagi you see and
before you
land the foot floats
here so not too much information but I'd
like you to do the cge if you want to
slip in the shaggies just to get your
mind focused on where they're
fitting but what I don't want to see is
your hands going limp because you're
starting to
think all right it's all today is all
about
this John John said to me say John said
to me Co you got to really work on that
wrist I said do marot Dory like you was
he went oh
yeah so when we do marot d
we we really work on our risk don't
we and then we put it down and forget
about it again well so today I'm saying
you're working on your morot Dori sh
naggi you're working on your morot Dori
kot it's still here just cuz it's in a
different place it doesn't mean to say
that it hasn't got the same Dynamics
okay H go